in this cloud minute I want to show you  how to deploy matrix of second server on  a Google compute engine instance in  Google cloud developer console go to  competition and create an instance give  it a name select its zone and the  machine type for boot disk choose one of  the sequel server images provided and  he's crate  once the instance is ready you can  create a Windows user and password and  Remote Desktop into it like any other  Windows instance once logged in you can  use sequel server management studio to  connect and manage the sequel server  instance  you can check out the links in the  description of the video for more  information thanks for watching